our next speaker once had to be rescued
in the middle of the Pacific Ocean when
the dive booat she was on
sank yes she's here of us now so clearly
she survived
Melissa so yeah it works on my machine
uh reproducibility and R for small teams
so some of you if you're Microsoft shops
at work probably recognize the sticker
from teams it's my favorite one to use
when I just can't deal with all the
problems anymore uh and I think it says
a lot that it's stock uh imagery in the
teams
chat so a few disclaimers before I get
started I work for New York State DEC
the Department of Environmental
Conservation but these opinions are on
my own and do not reflect any agency
policy and also everything but that
first image was generated with Adobe
Firefly so some of them are a little
weird and that's
why okay so about me I am not a computer
programmer I am not a software engineer
I don't do
statistics I'm a marine
biologist and that's a pretty cool job
title uh it starts a lot of
conversations and people have a lot of
ideas about what it means to be a marine
biologist and what a marine biologist
does so you know people think we work at
SeaWorld or we're out swimming with
dolphins
or a research vessel out in the ocean
for you know a week at a time um and
that is adobe's rendition of a of a Noah
research
vessel it's okay but uh there are many
people who do do that work as a mar
biologist but I'm not one of them I get
super seasick so that is not the work
for
me so what I ended up doing is working
with Fisheries data so this means mostly
catch an effort like who's fishing where
when how and how much they're catching
and I can do this All safely from my
Cube on land uh where I don't have to
worry about severe emotion sickness but
what it means that I do is the same
thing most of you probably do a lot of
data cleaning getting the data to the
people who need it running my own
analysis and then writing lots of
reports and I use R for most things I do
at work these days
obviously I'm using it to automate
everything uh there's so much you end up
doing and if you have to do it more than
three times you might as well automate
it and I hate doing repetitive work
anyway so that's worked out really great
but most recently I've been enjoying
using it to generate all of my reports
so often we have to run I don't know
thousands of IND individualized reports
at a time where they're drawing from
multiple data sources and the content of
those reports uh is very spefic specific
to the individual certain sections might
apply to one individual but not another
and I don't want to have to separate
those people out
first and this has been like a huge
success and saved a lot of work
everybody loves it um but I'm not
actually going to talk about it today
that today what I want to talk about is
what happens when you have that success
you've created this thing you've proven
your concept it's in production and now
what do you have to do to keep it
going before we get into it though uh
for the purposes of this talk a small
team is around 10 people or less and I'm
going to add the caveat that they have
limited to no experience with
r most many people are trained in
something else and find that they have
to learn uh you know how to code to do
their jobs effectively so they're coming
from you know biology ecology chemistry
backgrounds but they have to they have
to learn these tools in order to to
Really succeed at their job and often
there's no Enterprise tools there's no
it resources to devote to this
it's no Enterprise are our studio and
any of the tools that go with it it's
all local on your machine maybe you have
a shared file server
somewhere all right so you've done all
this stuff you made this new thing
you're really proud of it it's in
production now you have to share that
that workload amongst your team because
you can't be the sole purpose the sole
purpose who maintains this forever it's
a terrible feeling being the bottleneck
when everybody's waiting on you to get
something done or uh you know if you
come back from vacation full of dread
because you don't know what happened
while you are
gone so what happens after you implement
this big change who's responsible for
the maintenance and who's responsible
for making new
features so after a lot of Googling um I
found that the consensus was I should be
using our projects I should be using
GitHub I should be creating my own
packages and uh there's also a lot of
the information out there about rn rn I
don't even know how to pronounce that
they should have made that easier to say
um and of course after reading all this
information no one seemed to have any
problems with any of this on the
internet um and spoiler Al
alert I
did nothing worked first time the 10th
time um I did all the things I sent my
projects off to co-workers to try to run
and it was a huge failure uh it took
several several tries through to get to
get anything to work you know we saw all
the classic errors there's no packages
there's no
data they can't find your file
path and you don't have the right
permissions
and when you're working with you know a
team
that is newer isn't as experienced in
our uh that can all be hugely
frustrating and really prevent them from
kind of buying into this new uh these
new set of tools mostly people who had
experience with r python could debug in
real time and get it to work but you
shouldn't have to it should be
seamless all right so I'm going to go
through all these those things I just
mentioned
the problems I had with them some
approaches I took to try to mitigate
those I also decided I was going to
learn Cordo for this presentation so
that just an
extra uh challenge to to throw in there
so our
projects this I thought was like a base
level of knowledge that anyone who was
using are had heard of and that did not
turn out to be the case most issues we
have with our projects were people not
using projects as they were
intended so people didn't understand
that it was more than just a folder that
it had all this special information that
you know helped our find things and keep
track of your history and all these
bonus things and I would find staff
uh in the worst case scenario just
opening scripts from several different
projects trying to run them in no
project and everything was failing
because our couldn't find anything or
they would bring in scripts from other
places to their project and again our
couldn't find everything so it would
fail and they would get
frustrated uh so you know
unsurprisingly you know they don't they
weren't feeling good about what they
were doing um you know with the team and
the only way around that unfortunately
is to just you know train your people
better and making sure there's
onboarding in process and continued
training so
that they know what you
know um and as I mentioned you know
relative paths are great and for ad hoc
analysis sometimes an our project is all
you need to be able to run it quickly on
somebody else's machine if it's
something that you're never going to do
again you know next we started using
GitHub and GitHub
repositories this had a significant
learning curve
and the workflow involved in GitHub
remembering to you know Fork a project
check for sing your project with the
main project or S your sync your repo
with the main repo to make sure you're
getting changes was very alien to people
who aren't coming from that type of
workflow normally so we would run into
to lots of
problems um just with behaviors and
remembering to do this so again things
wouldn't work and every time something
doesn't work people get discouraged and
that's definitely not what you want on
your
team however once once it people got
that that workflow down it was the EAS
easiest way to get code onto somebody's
machine and the most important piece of
it is when they Fork a repo they can do
whatever they want to the repo without
ruining everything and it's so important
for people to have room to mess up
colossally and have it be okay otherwise
people aren't going to be willing to
help you maintain things and build new
features going forward excuse
me so after after that happened I
decided it was time
that we make our own package for our
office and this was really
intimidating
but and it still has the same problems
of keeping everything in sync you'll
hear me say that on every slide having
the same thing for every person all the
time is been really tricky when you
don't have um you know larger scale it
resources to help you
out and then who's going to maintain
this package forever because once you
become dependent on it if a
breaks are you going to go back to excel
I hope
not um and it also allows me to assign
more work to other people so perhaps
before I was the only one who could do
certain analysis because I knew I had to
look here here and here and filter it
this way to get the right data set but
now when we put it in a package
everybody can do that so everyone's
treating the data the same they're
starting with with apples to
apples and I'm sure oops I'm sure a lot
of you have the same experience that 90%
of what you do is the exact same thing
everywhere so if you can make that
easier that's a huge time saer and
reduces your own errors as
well
lastly we we're trying out our our end
and we've had constant Pro problems with
package versions on people's machines
depending on when someone was hired they
might have a different version of our
hundreds of different versions of
packages combinations on everybody's
machine uh you know we're not supposed
to install all that oursel it is
supposed to do that but you can't tell
it what to do and you end up with a
situation where everybody's just
confused and nothing
works so we've picked a few projects to
start trying this out at and this has
been the hardest thing about uh r that I
think I've ever done getting this to
work properly
um it's this might be our our own system
um I'm not really sure but it's so slow
to boot up like if I ask someone to run
this project they clone it from GitHub
by the time our studio is
done installing all the parts of that
R&V lock file it could be an hour and my
projects aren't that big we're not big
data and
that's pretty
frustrating often times
s staff will have to do something else
while it's running and have to shut it
down and it's it's just a bad feeling
again when you're trying to get new
people on board and to feel successful
and want to uh you know help you move
forward with
things we also ran into issues where
staff were updating the lock file
themselves which defeats the entire
purpose
um they should be using the packages
that I developed the project with but
then they were switching out and just
overwriting their lock file so things
weren't working again
so this is still a work in
progress but it has helped me write
better code in the sense that
um I shouldn't use R&V until I'm almost
done with the project when there's so
much in flux it's not really helpful
when it's just me working on it anyway
and it's also forced me to minimize the
amount of dependencies I
use uh so there's less room for mistakes
if you're pulling less
packages
so my main takeaways when you're working
on this small team um that doesn't have
you know a budget or or support and
you're trying to move forward um and do
new and Innovative things in our or even
other software
platforms is that you can't ignore
documentation training and being
consistent about
it what you say while you're talking to
someone they're not going to remember it
has to be written down somewhere there
has to be something they can fall back
on if you're not
there you also need to simplify
everything whenever you
can as you're working on projects you
might try things and like the remnants
of them are still there and that those
things might not be necessary anymore
but they're still causing problems so
you need to get rid of all that stuff
that's not important and keep everything
focused on the actual point of the
project and lastly it's it's important
to avoid scope creep in your projects I
might start a project with this one
analysis in mind but someone asked me a
slightly different question but I can
cheat by going back to this analysis and
then I keep building on it and things
get messy and you just again run into
more problems it's harder to break it
away when it's time to you know R run an
analysis that you need in 15
minutes so what's our next step
after
this so I'm I'm recently experimenting
with you know containers um I normally
have always thought of like things like
Docker and podman as being kind of a
large it issue that I would need a lot
of help to to roll out uh but honestly
working this has been just as
frustrating as RN so why not um
and all the code I've been talking about
previous to the slide has been code that
I've wrote that I want other people to
run and maintain but I also would like
other members of the team to start
writing their own code and I think a
container is a safer more friendly way
for them to do that um
where everything that they need is set
and there's just less ways that they can
run into to mistakes
I didn't put this on the slide but I'm
just going to throw it out there anyway
of all the problems we've had we have
never ever had a problem with a shiny
app run locally I don't know why but
we've been running some apps for years
and there's never been an issue whereas
other projects that are less complicated
seem to constantly have um hit snags so
I don't know why but perhaps I should be
writing more things in
chiny
so that's all thank you for listening um
all my slides are on my GitHub it's m
Hegman and the repos 2023 arav uh you
can also find me on LinkedIn it's
Melissa albino Hegman I'm the only one
there um yeah and I look forward to to
talking to you guys later and hearing
about your own struggles working with
your your co-workers in small teams
thank
you